well a selfless person will always put
someone else's needs before their own
and we found a remarkable woman who does
that and so much more
trudy para killman and her non-profit
which helps our cities homeless with the
essentials
overnight trudy para kilman went from
gainfully employed cocktail waitress
mother and wife
to a widow raising two sons it was an
eye opener
i had never needed the system before in
my life
[Music]
the death of her husband led to a series
of financial setbacks
health challenges and soon the brink of
homelessness
it was just like you know a shrug of the
shoulders and well
do you have a car well of course i have
a car but you expect me to sleep in it
with two boys with disabilities
that was seven years ago okay betty what
else do you want anything
trudy turned her life around and came
face to face with her true calling thank
you
as a homeless advocate creating the
compassion initiative
lv we're kind of a mobile department
store we have just about
a little bit of everything
[Music]
distributing with dignity doling out
necessities to the overlooked
the operation runs almost entirely on
generosity i
come home from dropping pantry boxes
and i might find my entire driveway full
of blankets
and jeans and sneakers and whatever it
is that we're collecting
trudy and her volunteers spend all of
their time
we're live on g street in the very place
they were trying to avoid
the streets of las vegas we will never
step away from our hands on connection
with these people
this is what they miss this is what they
need
they need somebody to know that somebody
cares by providing home-cooked meals
laundry clothing
and survival gear she works tirelessly
to make sure these faces
are not ignored
while at the same time caring for a 20
year old son with autism
and a teenager facing neurosurgery if
you're not
comfortable with the term remarkable
woman what kind of woman
would you be i'd say passionate would be
yes definitely not remarkable
to me that is that's mother teresa
and i'm hardly a mother teresa
but i mean you're doing god's work yes
yes and i wish that
many of the people that hopefully will
be watching this
remembers that we are doing god's work
and it's not
illegal to feed people who are in need
what we need are more remarkable women
like trudy para killman
[Music]
so throughout this past month we have
been sharing the remarkable stories of
four women here in southern nevada now
these finalists were chosen literally
from hundreds of nominees
and then coming up this thursday right
here at 4 30 we are going to reveal the
winner
who will then be in the running to be
named our next star
woman of the year next star by the way
is the company that owns this television
station and hundreds of others across
the country
you don't want to miss our big reveal
coming up on thursday